all right you may have a seat sir thank
you you remain under oath
go ahead mr bennett
uh mr stick we we left off at well we
were about to view some photos of that
white handgun you have in front of you
so i'll be showing you it's been marked
as s 370 371 373 and 374.
ladies and gentlemen at the break the
court and counsel uh did discuss certain
additional photographs that were moved
into evidence no objection by the
defense and the court accepted those so
those are
363 365 367 and 368 370 371
and
373 through 376. those are all admitted
in the evidence go ahead mr bennett
thank you
uh mr stick uh s370 as it appears on
your screen um is how the gun was
presented to you at the time of
examination correct yes sir
and the skip 371 as it is the
same gun removed from the box correct
yes
now looking at s373
what does this photo depict uh that's a
view looking down the slide to the
where the firing pin should be
and can you demonstrate or explain to us
where the firing pin should be this
picture sure if we look down the top
part of the slide you'll see the
circle in the back in the center
that's just an empty hole that would be
where the firing pin would
protrude and looking now to this 374
um
what is the hole we see in the center
of this picture
within the barrel in the center right
there
the one we're looking at there's the the
two holes the one on the right would be
your firing pin hole
or aperture
and what's the hole in the left
that would be where the extractor would
be
and you would say earlier that both of
those were missing from the spawner
correct
making it you know
correct
okay
um you could return that box down
support please and uh if you could
retrieve what's been marked s 199
do you recognize that byron
yes sir
and is that one of the farms you
examined on december 18th 2019 yes sir
it is
and the last two firearms you identified
which were s-177 and s-200 those were
both semi-automatic pistols as you
described correct
um and is this a different style of
handgun yes sir it is
and what side would that be the revolver
um can you hold that box up for the jury
so they know which weapon you're talking
about
and looking
to what's been marked as uh s 367. is
that the same firearm you see before you
yes sir
and can you describe the parts of each
part in this function of this firearm
and you could feel free to come down and
judge it that's okay if you can find the
screen sure
starting at the top this would be your
bearer front sight a little hard to set
your rear sight is actually behind the
zip tie
this would be your grip panel
your back strap
that would be your hammer
this part here is the
cylinder release this part is the
cylinder
the ejector rod and this part is where
it swings out it's called the crane
we have our
trigger and our trigger guard
and i believe you've mentioned before
but can you just walk the very quickly
through how you load this firearm
specifically sir what you have to do is
pull this to the rear the cylinder would
swing out then you'd be able to
load this on
and how many rounds does this farm in
particular hold this one
and um
we could return to your scene mr
and did you have the opportunity to
examine that firing for operability
yes sir
and was that farm submitted with any
ammunition in it or with it
no sir
was that firearm ultimately be
determined to be operable yes sir it was
and that was done using ammunition you
have from your supply in the u.s correct
and during the course of your
examination um
you took photos from this firearm
yes sir and one of those photos is
what's been trump used 367 yes sir it is
and is s 360 at the same time removed
from the box it is
okay
now you can return that box to the
ground
and um if you can retrieve the last box
which has been marked s201 which is
early evidence
2017
do you recognize that farm that's before
you yes sir
and is that also one of the farms you
examined december 18th 2019. yes sir it
is
and i'm going to show you um what has
been marked as s375
is that the farm that you have before
you
yes there it is and that depicts the way
it was presented to you during
examination yes sir
um are the parts on this farm
generally the same as the farm we just
viewed yesterday are there any
differences between the two of those yes
sirs and what difference would that be
um and the um the way you would load it
okay
and judge i would ask just to show the
difference if mr stick can come down and
point to the different piece of this
firearm that makes it unique
go ahead you may step down sir
the previous revolver did use the
cylinder release with this one it's a
fixed cylinder
so what you have to do is call the gate
what you do is open that gate and you
would
load the cylinder one at a time
you would load it you'd have to spin it
load it again rotate that cylinder until
they were all full
and how many rounds does this particular
gun hold
and what caliber round is this this one
is a 22l
and earlier had mentioned or i'd ask you
a question rather regarding actions what
action does this revolver have uh this
one is a single action and can you
remind the jury what that means
regarding trigger pulls sure for the
trigger pull you'd be one
action want to pull the trigger wood
releases the environment in order to do
another shot what would you have to do
you would have to cut down
on each shot yes
and uh did you you could return your
same sorry
did you also have an opportunity to
review this firearm with regard to
operability yes sir and was this firearm
determined to be operable yes sir it was
was this fire presented to you with any
ammunition at the time of testing no sir
and you utilized your own supply to
testify this weapon that's correct
and you take photographs during your
examination besides what we see on the
screen yes
is s376 as it appears before you um
the photo you took during examination
after removing that far from the box yes
sir it is
give me one second you're on
certainly
mr stitt i'm going to show you
two pictures that you took side by side
and we've previously seen already i'm
showing you it's been marked
as s-357
and s-371
um these are two of the farms we were
already discussing the examiner correct
yes sir
and
while they look the same do they
function in similar capacity to each
other they do
and when i say that what i mean is are
the same general steps taken to fire
each of these yes sir
however the one on the right was
determined to be inoperable inoperable
is that correct yes
no further questions josh
all right close examination mr valincus
that gun to the right that you just saw
that's the one that's inoperable correct
yes sir
you have no idea how
long that gun has been inaudible
no sir
you testified that the 45
was operable correct yes sir and is that
a much larger caliber
caliber
handgun
much more deadly because of the size of
the bullet the questions
please do
sustained
all right any follow-up mr bennett
redirect i mean
you may step down thank you very much
can i see council at the bench please
all right members of the jury we are
going to break now i know it's a little
bit early it's 3 35 currently there's a
couple reasons for that number one it's
friday that's the most important reason
i want you all to get at early start on
your uh weekend
and the case has progressed very nicely
i'm satisfied with the pace of the case
uh it's actually moved a little quicker
than i had
i had anticipated
so
because of those reasons i think it's a
good time to break the state anticipates
finishing their presentation of evidence
their case
on monday maybe in the morning maybe
early afternoon it depends but
the state's going to finish on monday
and then shortly thereafter we'll start
the defense case
all right so you you've heard some
evidence uh certainly from the stand but
not the whole case so please it's
important at this juncture not to
discuss the case among yourselves or
with anyone else
that only happens when you hear all the
evidence then you retire to deliberate
on the case
so with those brief comments have a nice
weekend everyone we'll see you monday
morning same time thank you enjoy your
weekend
[Music]
[Music]
all right this thing on for a minute
so mr schoenhorn have all your witnesses
here witnesses here monday morning so we
can try to
should i finish it
um
yeah i would you have some late
witnesses to call before you get to the
experts
officers who would be real quick and
other things
yeah but we wanted you but whatever
order you want but maybe the police
officers would be a good place to start
in the afternoon
judge i know that uh
mr bolinkis has been working with the
super franchisee about getting those
witnesses lined up but if i could just
ask to be notified
who they anticipate calling on sunday
and also i i was planning on
serving this
on edward
this weekend
you